foreign
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen of the jury
how y'all doing all y'all that don't
know who I am my name is Willie Gary
Willie Gary Willie William Gary never
heard of him what's so special about
this guy anyway
[Music]
ass kicking truth is I know you got
myself into a lot of trouble I've been
your lawyer 30 years we can find a way
out of it you've never sued anybody
before in your whole life I'm just going
to try to bully me out of business and I
don't think I should be expected to
stand for it Mr Gary hasn't lost a case
in over 12 years you suggesting I hire
this guy's one of my lawyers y'all come
on in pleasure to meet you Mr Gary let
me introduce you to my call Red how do
you feel about working with Blackpool I
suppose I am a little prejudice
Douglas
gentlemen he's suing us he's suing us we
are a half a billion dollar Corporation
so how much money y'all trying to get
eight million that ain't enough money
100 million dollars
[Laughter]
who is this clown he's hired as a lawyer
you're a fighter man what made you want
to do it because he tried to mess with
the one thing that means the most to me
in life being able to leave something
behind for my grandchildren
let's play some music
my name is Maine Downs graduated top of
her class from Harvard Law School they
had a nickname for her around the office
the python I wouldn't get too used to me
being kind to you Mr Gary once we begin
that trial
I want to destroy you
can't see it
snowball's chance in hell are winning
this case just just trust me okay I I
may have found something what does it
feel like to be some small time nobody
on the verge of bankruptcy
what if I don't win
and I let all these people down you have
been trying to turn this into your own
one ring circus I got my damn life on
the line I know that Jerry
did it ever bother you democracy the
hypocrisy you'll sit your ass down
I just put the pole can't split the pole
now come on
[Music]
yes hi I have some bad news we lost your
mom what sorry that was terrible
phrasing I meant we don't know where she
is
ah I think your sister's here and it's
finally happened oh my God it's okay
it's okay I'm here
she ran away
and yum your Mom owes me 80 grand when
you have it you'll get your dog back I
don't have any money you can sell your
eggs might sound like you're using them
no there has to be another way
what is the square root of 196 14.
correct how many hearts does an octopus
have they're incorrect what saffron
Saturn Aphrodite Apollo Aries carbon
dioxide the equal sign correct oh my God
what you know this game this is how
you're gonna make the money
Drive
races
races oh
all right
come on it's gonna be fun I'm not
sleeping on the floor I'm not sleeping
on the floor either I think on the chair
I don't want to sleep in a sitting
position oh my God
I can't play on live TV in front of
millions of people unless you get to it
and you gotta get through hair makeup I
already went through hair makeup oh and
you missed the spot I can't do this am I
sweating yeah you know what put your
arms down you're having a panic attack
doctors prescribe these is that cocaine
Stevia do you ever use Stevia the
sweetener yeah yeah
win or lose we'll do it together
that is definitely broken I bet you I
could pop it back in my sound no idea
I'm on your throat
cause girls how can I ever thank you
maybe like a drink later well I'm
married
I'm gay why'd you say two reasons
[Music]
Pebblebrook is threatening to sue it for
mishandling his case what your son is
online
how's your first day going I'm coming
home Honeys diners are not quitters
we're Fighters I'm not a fighter I'm a
daily upper decker
I don't even know what that means he
went to undergrad at Barnett University
you were president of your sorority and
popular with all the guys right I mean
yeah look at you my son is a really good
kid but he's a recluse I would like to
hire you to go back take him under your
wings would pay me to go back to Barnett
yeah Holly I'm getting paid to go back
to college and you're gonna come with me
you know I'm really sorry get back to
your station my apologies juice boxes
for everybody we have until homecoming
get this kid from Zero to Hero how are
you supposed to do that this is Paulie
and I'm Molly we're actually thinking
about going to Still Waters you should
come with us we could convince the girl
to come with us yeah it was in a
neighborhood and I just wanted to see oh
why do you want to help me so much we
all deserve a second chance at a first
impression I want to dedicate this shot
to my boy Elliot one two
three
you won't step foot in here again care
to make a wager on that booze kathalon
if we win Elliot gets big and if I win
I'll bounce Keys yes the whole car
you're on
[Music]
what's up
hey I need to help my son get adjusted
to college not ruin his life
just think of me as your little Gemini
cricket
[Applause]
tamale singer hope your second time
around is fine
give a little Spanky thing
and that's done there's an important
lesson and consent
holy
I will tell you I've never seen anything
like it holy
it's the craziest I think I've ever seen
everything okay
11 million dollars what are you gonna do
get a Ferrari what the oh language the
baby's here
yo what up everybody roaring Kitty here
I'm gonna pick a stock and talk about
why I think it's interesting and that
stock is Gamestop I love this guy
retail Traders I'm hooked into GameStop
I think they think it's a good
investment it looks like there's one guy
driving all the buying who is this
the money man I'm gonna take it
Wall Street is betting that this company
is gonna fail if it fails these hedge
fund people make a ton of money 70
000 people have watched this video
[Music]
if he's in I'm in if he's in I'm in
GameStop those shares not stopping don't
stop it's only gonna go up when they hit
I'm gonna buy you a mansion let's drink
to that my brother is a nerd Wall Street
must be seen this right you should
probably dial in holy do you have a
minute I uh
um
babe how much did we make today
what did we lose today a billion and
yesterday 4 million and yesterday a
billion
yeah
really really rich
you got rich dudes pissing in their
pants right now they're coming after you
we need to talk about the Game Stop
situation
retail Traders always lose you've been
served Wall Street cheated surprise
surprise you have to testify before
Congress the game has changed
[Music]
a lot of people feel the system is
broken the whole idea of the stock
market is if you're smart and maybe with
a little luck you can make your fortune
certainly not anymore
there's no hope for the little guy
balls
maybe now there is yeah
[Music]
hey Doc I was thinking tonight could be
a good night for sex night possibly
it's an interesting idea but you know
damn how's the new Opera coming along
good great great we had discussed seeing
a first draft of the score in two weeks
is it still all right I'm suffering from
a temporary blockage at the moment
no turn it back on
G5
is he all right he had a total breakdown
after his last album
I can't do this
we need to take a walk jolt your brain
out of its little rad pattern interact
with a stranger okay honey I have a
patient bye
are we going that way I keep imagining
you naked I don't know if you want to
hear more details about these images no
[Music]
about every one of these people has a
story for an opera and then Levi what do
you do I operate a Tempo the wrong hands
this tug is a deadly weapon
[Music]
isn't everybody I've been arrested for
stalking I had to go to rehab and uh I'm
not supposed to be doing this
I can't believe that actually happened I
mean she seduced me right she's a witch
the demented tugboat captain who knows
men to her Tugboat and kills them
beneath them I loved it how did you come
up with that
I was really angry at you and now it
turns out on your Muse oh see I'll never
leave you
um I love cleaning cleanliness is close
to Godliness where my patients are
talking I imagine getting inside their
heads with disinfectant and just
scrubbing them down
your Toughbook Captain came to see me
I'm in Love no no just admit that I had
a magic effect on me
imagination came up with the story my
talent wrote the music I mean you don't
kill men and eat them do you no I
haven't yet
I know I can't resist a romantic story
even if I'm not in it
[Music]
do you know that feeling when you're
doing exactly what you were put on the
earth to do the one where it's like
everything inside you is moving together
in harmony with the universe
me neither
but you know one can hope right
wave to Mommy because she'll hate me
even more than she already does if you
don't I seem to recall you saying that
becoming a lawyer would only crush your
soul yeah it is I'm running a business
right now that business is getting a
journalist in and out of paldonia
[Applause]
no no and no who's a journalist I have
resigned my position here
20 grand says you are
welcome president finaga so nice to meet
you
you must take a selfie you approved
us
foreign
I met the president of a country in the
middle of a coup this is the scoop of a
lifetime you got to be alive down the
scoop for a lifetime you never should
have come let's go you can't just leave
him
[Music]
I'm just doing my job
did you help
get up again man I got to win I get up
again
hey not the time for coaching man
oh my God
oh Color Me impressed Mr petite
tell me you got that run
[Music]
the K Santos
not on your life
hello girls
it's the last body shot competition so
we are gonna assault a you up
I've had it with love I don't believe
it's relevant to the 21st century
lesbian
you're not wearing that I just came from
work I came from Toledo I don't dress
like it I'm not here to Pedal my Wares
I'm leaving town I am too that was my
plan where are you going Tallahassee
Florida I've been unhappy that's why we
take this trip together honey babe we
get our act together together
girlies Drive Away Pennsylvania's most
trusted name in car delivery come on
here don't call me curly
in your name girl my name is Curly we
just met it's too familiar
we're here for the car wait a minute you
call with a drop off in Tallahassee and
then these broads come in and say
they're ready to go to Tallahassee they
drive the car instead of you is that bad
bad if they find the goods
what we should see what's in here I bet
it's locked
[Music]
[Applause]
I understand that you're unhappy sir we
will find and deliver the package we
just want your friends
you cannot relate to the public which in
the service profession is a big handicap
did the two creeps find you they know we
have their stuff maybe we sell it back
shake them down are they like wanted or
something oh no they're not in trouble
at all I'm gonna help you break a big
murder case that is about the dumbest
thing I've ever heard and I'm a cop
everybody
who are you Democrats
wow you've had a full day
foreign
looks like she hasn't been washed in
years I'll see you later baby it was
nice to meet you I really should find my
way back home we could help
we're completely lost and my little
puppy paw pads are really hurting right
now this could be a lot worse how could
this get worse
hold on Buddy
oh wow your balls look huge from this
angle thank you but holy
craziest thing I have ever seen and I'm
Dennis Quaid and Dennis Quaid has seen
some
starving how many of these shoes
all of them
you look different too how so is it my
human hands hold up
what do we do calm down I got this hello
officer none of us up
I sent you the royal wedding the simple
instructions
don't cause an international incident
how's it going
you've done some pretty stupid things in
your day but this thanks for the cake
[Music]
Henry shoved me an urge I currently
saved
what I need is some good old-fashioned
damaged control
the White House and the palace are going
to release a joint statement
you've got to be choking you can hate
Prince Henry all you want landia is
bigger than yours I want you to know
that they're wearing lifts no not too
sweetheart you better act like the
Sunshine's out of his ass and you have a
vitamin D deficiency I think excellent
is what you might say to convince the
world that we're actually friends I love
hanging out with this guys
[Music]
you know
did I do something wrong you don't
wonder who you'd be if you were an
anonymous person in the world I have no
idea what you're talking about
[Music]
yourself your majesty it's your Royal
Highness
dear Alex I miss you
we are in a hotel crawling with
reporters if anyone sees you leave this
hotel I will brexit your head from your
body your Royal Highness
he'd figure out if you feel forever
about him do you love him what
difference
Henry belongs to Britain we can figure
out a way to love each other on our own
terms it's like there's a rope attached
to my chest and it keeps pulling me
towards you
hopefully we'll get there tonight
without any more scandals
the night is young Ma
I told you
I'm on vacation while I'm on vacation
I'ma just float come here
Marcus and Emily Parker you have failed
to notify your airline that you are
registered sex offenders
[Laughter]
what the hell is wrong with you
look at us all together again we just
wanted to give you guys a real honeymoon
just found this crawling under our table
he's crawling
time it's a prodigy it's amazing
if they do it letting us in a place
that's nice how the hell did you get us
in here you didn't tell him they gonna
be long gone by the time I get into my
work thing you must be Mr Parker
apologies for the change in schedule Mr
Young is invited you for drinks all of
you guys I need you to be really cool
can you do that for me
[Music]
[Applause]
look who you're talking to when have we
ever not been cool
released from San Quentin
I got you the best wedding present what
why does this coconut taste cookie
because it's your mom is so with your
mom it's really kind of beautiful if you
think about it no this is not our
picture things going at all it's cool
Marcus is cool right
get your hands off my wife
ever since he showed up he turned this
relaxing family vacation to total chaos
who does that
why don't we just go back I knew it
chicken it's only one thing left to do
sir
yeah
I've never seen that much water come up
a person before
your butthole threw up bud
[Music]
I'd like to report a crime that hasn't
happened yet have you seen the movie
Back to the Future basically I'm living
that movie right now which is how I know
there's gonna be a murder tonight
hey time travel movies it never make any
sense
[Music]
hard this time of year is for us your
friends were murdered 35 years ago it's
not 1987 anymore stay safe honey I love
you
thank you
what the
excuse me what year is it 1987. oh my
God I know the 80s are almost over and I
haven't even tried Coke yet
I don't know
oh my God Mom
off and die Jesus mom Mamacita
for my birthday
this is the creepiest cabin in the
middle of nowhere what's the big
deal there is a murderer on the loose
and you drove us into the woods
I forgot to bring vodka
you have seven and a half hours until
you're stuck here forever
horror before it happens
she's kill us all no they more just rip
apart the fabric of our society via
dance videos on Tick Tock face dance
against us
come on out Waters warm just so you know
I don't do you pee out of that
thing
I think hey hey you did do
it'll be alive
yeah let's not make that the lesson
[Music]
80s when it sucks this is just dirt look
at all these Twigs I could give you a
gummy this big that has 100 times more
weed than this
foreign
[Music]
All-Star Baker my best friend since
second grade hero of the night would you
make it Jay James I love this cake I
love this girl she talked to more men
tonight than she has in the past 23
years combined
Street when you're done channeling with
Hadid sisters get to my office Look at
me now Look at me now I thought about
this cake thing you're gonna start doing
it bringing cakes into bars one cake a
week for a year and I thought of a name
cake Barn
[Music]
I'm bumping you up to Junior agent can I
hug you yes leave anything stronger than
aspirin
I got the results of Quinn's MRI it's
not what we were hoping for
if you're at home and your mother and I
can help you stay on top of this she
won't be on her own
[Applause]
hi I need this
feel like you should be getting more
rest I just want to have fun and I want
you to have fun I wish it could be about
funds as your caregiver it's perfect
thank you so much nurse caregiver for
making sure that everything sucks all
the time
[Music]
we're gonna look back on all this as
that weird year we spent in hospitals
and Mars
[Music]
[Applause]
sometimes I wish I was you sometimes I
wish I was you for the most amazing
person I've ever known
[Music]
do you know what the greatest thing
about America is you can make things
happen here like nowhere else
you have the power to create your own
future if you can be anything you can do
anything
you want to sell high-end stuffed
Himalayan cats under stuffed actually
for greater posability we're
professionals we're giving the people
what they need
[Music]
the latest numbers we broke the entire
internet thing
or you go home
[Music]
I would tell you he did it all
which is as crazy as believing stuffed
animals are gold
did you see the truck crash
poor beanies
this has always been my company company
we created together you have to be so
dramatic I mean my salary has been
reduced 75 percent yeah I'm just doing
what's necessary you know running the
real actual business over here
[Music]
my life is
this inspiration 99 presentation
that's not how the saying goes
everything good that's happened to me is
because if you guys we are bonded
forever
countless times
[Music]
I have our perfect Partners lined up
Jehovah's Witnesses the greatest
one-on-one salesman in the world how
brilliant is that
gonna go
[Music]
I only want to speak to Oprah Winfrey
has she reached out
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
guess that's you guys
tonight is our night we're heading in
the couch I'm gonna talk to Brittany you
get that Isabelle what would I say hey
girl how's your boyfriend how's his
penis
[Music]
I'm gonna expel you both for committing
a crime against Jeff get out of the car
[Music]
we were just practicing for a
self-defense club like a Fight Club yes
just stay in your lane until you're
munching Beaver Wesleyan yes sir
what's your plan here Jeff is psychotic
and they're picking on the weak and
defenseless so we teach a bunch of girls
how to defend themselves they are
grateful to us adrenaline is Flowing
next thing you know Isabelle and
Brittany are kissing us on the mouse
be our club advisor you know my mom did
say I needed to pick up a hobby
what club let's get it
[Applause]
we'll have a safe space like this it
means a lot to people I'm gonna finally
reverse stock my stalker yeah I'll be
able to kill my stepdad awesome
seems so supportive of women especially
the hot ones man-made therapy
are you cheating on me I literally saw
you yesterday some nerd I your
mom
where to open up
[Music]
your clock is over
they deserve a shot at showing everybody
how cool they are
hot places
I know y'all ain't tickling the Pearl I
just don't know if you're supposed to be
talking to us like that just like as a
teacher
I never fit in anywhere to Iranian in
America to American and Iran
the only way to survive was to not put
my faith in any of the rules nice
cultural commentary
obviously I've had some issues with
culture can you blame me
what's she saying I'm pregnant how can
you be so irresponsible
this is my mom and I's relationship in a
nutshell she's a she's the queen of
stubbornness a trait I'd later go on to
perfect
Elena Hi how are you evidently better
than you
time to let go of that anger I'm trying
it's not all my mom's fault I believe in
you but it's so much easier blaming on
Mothers how do you say goodbye in Persia
hi for sure everybody
[Music]
All-American family
just me on this
[Music]
sir I don't understand that's glaringly
apparent I can't fail this class oh
don't tell yourself short Mr coats I
truly believe that you can
every year at Martin Academy students
faculty and staff depart the campus for
a two-week winter break but there are
always an unfortunate few who have
nowhere to go for the holidays they're
known as the holdovers Mr hanum hello
Mary I had you guys stuck with
babysitting duty this year how'd you
manage that you know it used to be a
student right yeah that's why he knows
how to inflict maximum pain on them
I thought all the Nazis were hiding in
Argentina
you just earned yourself a detention sir
being here with you is already one big
attention son of a that's another
detention do you think I want to be
babysitting you no I was praying your
mother would pick up the phone or your
father would arrive in a helicopter or a
flying saucer father dead
you don't tell a boy that's been left
behind at Christmas that nobody wants
him what's wrong with you there's nobody
here okay you stay out of my way and
I'll stay out of yours let me sleep
most of the kids dislike you pretty much
hate you teachers too you know that
right I find the world a bitter and
complicated place and it seems to feel
the same way about me I think I have
this in common
I don't think I've ever had a real
family Christmas like this before
thank you Mary you're welcome history is
not simply the study of the past it is
an explanation of the present see when
you say it that way and throw in some
pornography it's a lot easier to
understand
I'd like to propose a toast to my two
unlikely companions
are you trying to lift down my shirt no
yes you're gonna get me fired this is
your Rubicon do not cross
the holdovers
[Music]
foreign
the only thing I have from the dad I
never knew is half of a locker we must
be brothers that's just brothers Trevor
twins wow we're twins we're
identical twins if mom and dad got
married again then we'd have a real
family what if we trick them into
getting back together
what are you doing here the twins
[Music]
the services
should I open another bottle I know it's
our second but we're not Baptist
[Music]
way y'all up
I'm gay queer is a three dollar bill in
just as thin
my hand job
[Applause]
[Music]
wow a lady boss I guess it really is the
year that it is
I'm so sorry did you say sewer boys
disgusting they're not disgusting
they're gay kosher
oh
[Applause]
start from the beginning
yo Bizzle click clock it's show time is
it some type of prank call sign this
ain't no pranks we play this is crime
War 2K live and diving in your face
click like hey sprinkle if you wanted to
play with a big hard toy then you should
have just asked you know I was just
joking in it shut up you please
stop the music fan sorry fam click clack
Barry got the weapons
are you on it or not yeah
we can eat some more soldiers I'm gonna
call my man a minute I ain't got time
for your CBBC man in blood this time you
do something that's gonna finally put us
on the map give me everything you've got
Pals 10ps
you want the pennies stop me I might
actually take
ring ring is your mommy on the
phone
I love that
is
you are beautiful hold on
hello can't you see this he's a double
yellow light
can you not do that
part of your brother allow it waste man
cake
I locked me up like some cage animal
they say 12 Years a Slave Kazi this is
some other Hood
your booze don't smell like they used to
sleep
Harper has his first new zombie movie
coming out in over 30 years no one knows
anything about it except it'll Premiere
here exclusively in carverville
Halloween night
is the projector ready
[Music]
anything else no start the movie
is this
you just roll the film and it turns the
actors into the Living Dead
power to suck the souls out of everyone
in this vicinity we can stop them from
spreading as Marion had all the
knowledge if he were here he'd know what
to do your films must be burnt you have
to destroy them all go to the theater
stop the projector that's the last film
no freaking way
I just got my driver's license you can
drive
[Applause]
get away from it
[Music]
hit him on the head
we're in really big trouble we'll never
watch another zombie movie again
hurry up
[Music]
oh God can you drive
have you seen my kid
should have been home an hour ago your
mom is gonna be very upset with you
I love your costume which right oh it's
not a costume I was sweeping the floor
okay fine one month detention please
foreign
[Music]